like skipper said my name is Brian lang
I'm a partner and a data scientist at
data scope before I get rolling on this
talk which I'll do shortly because we've
got a lot to cover I just want to give
you a heads up the audience for this
talk is really intended to be people who
are sort of new to machine learning or
have tinkered with it a little in the
past but don't really feel like they
have a sense of what's actually
happening when they import something
from scikit-learn so if you're the kind
of person who can spend an hour reading
about gradient boosting online and
understand everything that you're
reading this may not be the talk for you
may be a little sort of higher level
then then you would expect next door one
of the pandas maintainer z-- is talking
about scikit-learn and pandas data types
so if you want to take off I won't take
any offense last thing this talk is kind
of a survey I'm trying to cover as many
algorithms in the next 45 minutes as we
reasonably can so I'm going to gloss
over some things I'm going to move
quickly we could neck beard out about a
lot of the sort of details of of these
things and how they're implemented in
encode but I'm gonna try and sort of
stay above that to give you a high-level
understanding and hopefully inspire you
to learn more about some of these
methods so I mentioned I'm a partner in
a data scientist at data scope data
scope is a design they're the science
consultancy but we kind of think of
ourselves as a mixture of a few
different kinds of firms something like
a design firm like an idea of something
like a consulting firm like an Accenture
something like an analytics firm like a
Palantir IBM of course we're a lot
smaller and less well-known than all of
those companies but you kind of get the
idea what that really means is that I
work with some really freaking smart
people which is where I learned pretty
much all of this stuff my background is
really more of a software one I kind of
stumbled across data scope a few years
ago and became really interested in the
data science side of things and have
been learning about about machine
learning and statistics and all that
stuff along the way so all that said
we're going to talk about classification
algorithms today so if you're not
familiar these are a technique from
machine learning that can kind of be
down two I have a distinct number of
groups or buckets and I have a bunch of
data points and I want to sort those
into the correct bucket or the right
group popular examples one that I'm
gonna use a lot during the talk today
just because it's an easy one to kind of
get your head around is a spam filter so
you can think of a spam filter as you
have a data points or emails right you
need to classify them into is this spam
or is this not spam and if you use Gmail
these days it's doing even more than
that it's a multi class classifier right
it's classifying it into is this
promotional email or is this something
you might actually want to read another
popular example of a classification
algorithm would be the sorting hat from
Harry Potter
so it's it's taking whatever it can tell
by sitting on top of your head and being
a magical hat and using that data to try
and sort you correctly into one of these
four houses right so some things to know
before we jump in classification is
what's considered a supervised learning
technique which means that you need data
that has labels with the correct answers
on it before you can do this you can't
just say here are my four groups I'm
going to throw a bunch of emails at you
you figure it out you have to give these
algorithms examples so that they can
learn some terminology things so I'm
gonna probably more or less
interchangeably use the words feature
dimension column attribute these are
sort of well they're features of the
data right they're things like in the
case of an email what percentage of the
email is all caps or how many words are
in the email or they're like columns in
a database whereas I'll use the words
class category label and these are your
your Harry Potter house right these are
the groups that we're sorting things
into alright one more caveat before we
get started with the algorithm stuff I'm
gonna talk about algorithms for the next
40 minutes or so
but and I think a lot of times when
people are first learning about machine
learning stuff there's a is a real
emphasis on wanting to learn about all
the algorithms because you look at the
scikit-learn documentation and you're
like wow look at all these different
things I can
like I want to know how all of them work
and what the exact right one to choose
is but a lot of times when you're
working on problems like this gathering
more data or making better use of the
data that you have by selecting the
right features or combining them in a
creative way or pulling in data from a
third source and sort of merging it in
to make make the data richer is actually
going to produce sort of more drastic
improvements than just switching from
one algorithm to another it's not always
the case it depends a lot on your
problem you're gonna hear me say that
phrase a lot over the next 40 minutes
but just something to keep in mind while
we nerd out about all of these methods
okay so with all that said let's look at
our sort of toy problem for today here's
a scatter plot that I together of some
emails so I mentioned we'll do the spam
filter thing so the red red dots here
are spam emails blue ones are not spam
and the two features that I'm choosing
here to make this plot are the number of
mentions of brand names in an email and
the percent of the email body that is
all caps so in reality you probably have
a lot more information than this but I'm
gonna flatten this down to two
dimensions you'll see people and machine
learning do this a lot just because it's
much easier to draw in 2d than it is
draw in 3d and much much easier than
drawing in four or five six seven
dimensions so so keep in mind that you
know this is kind of an
oversimplification but this will help us
sort of understand what's happening with
with some of these different methods so
I'm going to start with something called
a linear discriminant method and this is
so we're human beings with eyes and
brains and pattern matching abilities
right we were to look at this image and
Trank the way that we might distinguish
the spam mills from the not we might say
well what if we just draw a line right
here and we say everything above that
line is spam and everything below that
line is not spam we would do a pretty
good job right we would get one of these
wrong there's some savvy spammer in the
bottom here who's that an on all caps
email that's not just doesn't just say
Gucci over and over again my text
get through a spam filter but in
classification this line that we drew is
what we would call a decision boundary
and the decision boundary is sort of a
shape that determines which of these
categories a data point is going to fall
into so we drew this one because we're
reasonable people but we could have
drawn something like this and for each
decision boundary we can quantify how
good or bad that boundary is by looking
at sort of how many did we get wrong
right there's a lot of different ways to
measure error and that's something I
don't have time to get into today but in
this case we drew this line we're
getting five emails wrong if we draw
this line we're getting four emails
wrong the original one we were only
getting one wrong so we can compare
these lines to sort of determine what
the best line is and if you remember
from middle school geometry we can
represent these lines using numbers
right so if we have a point or intercept
and a slope we can describe what that
line is that we use to sort of determine
the cutoff for is this spam or not and
those are called coefficients right
those numbers that determine the line so
if we plot those coefficients and how
good or bad the line is in three
dimensions we get what's called an air
surface and you can actually see or a
map of terribleness as I call it on the
slides so what we're trying to seek here
is how do we come up with the least
terrible line to divide this thing into
spam and not spam and I won't get into
the sort of like extreme details of this
but one method for doing that is
basically what's called gradient descent
which is kind of rolling a ball down
that surface finding the area where it
settles into the least crappy line that
we can find there are other methods for
doing this too but gradient descent is
kind of at the heart of a lot of machine
learning methods not all of the ones
we'll talk about today but some of them
so you can read more about that if
you're interested ok cool so what did we
just do
we had some training data I threw a few
Python snippets into this thing I'm
probably going to go through them
relatively quickly but just to kind of
just
how would you actually do this with code
right so we have some training data and
in the in the case of Python and
particularly using scikit-learn which is
a popular machine learning library that
I'm gonna use in my examples today
you're usually going to have a is all of
your feature information so in this case
you can think of that the XY coordinates
of these things or the for the emails
that percent all caps and the number of
Rand mentions and then you'll have a
separate one that has the labels for
each of those points such that you know
the first label here matches up with the
first point second label here matches up
with the second point and those labels
are numbers in Python but those numbers
actually correspond to the classes or
categories that we are looking to sort
things into I'm so one in this case
being not spam to being spam okay so we
took that training data and we created a
model out of it right
in scikit-learn you'd do this by
importing whatever method you want to
use of course I picked one that has like
the longest name and that entire library
linear from linear discriminant analysis
import linear discriminant analysis
it's the anyway so so you create to that
muckle that some of you are probably
familiar with this but just to give you
sort of an example of how simple it is
that's you're feeding into fit then that
x and y that we defined just before so
once you've called this it actually
changes that model object and saves the
information that contains that bound or
that defines that boundary in that
object so we actually have a trained
model now that's entirely independent of
the original training data that we use
to train it it's its own thing if you
were to take that model and save it like
for example into a pickle file or
something like that it's not going to
contain every email that we fed into it
in the first place it's going to contain
enough to be able to make decisions but
not necessarily all of the training data
itself we have like an abstract idea of
what spam is and isn't so now that you
know the exciting part is you have a new
data point you have a new email you want
to be able to mark it as spam or not
right
so you feed that into the model and in
Python that might look something like
this
you have your new point you call model
dot predict pass the point in print out
the results and it's one which if you
remember is predicting that this email
is not spam because it fell in the blue
section of our model so most of the time
people aren't going to use a linear
discriminant classifier there are cases
where if you need to train a bunch of
classifiers for some reason these are
pretty quick but there are better
options these days which we're gonna get
into now I just use this as sort of a
way to start getting you into this
terminology and how I'm going to present
the rest of these so one of those that
you might actually use as logistic
regression again there's more details
here but in practice it works a lot like
what we just talked about except for
that instead of having that hard border
of we drew a line through it there's
actually sort of a gradient between your
two classes in the form of a logistic
function so so there's shades of gray
that a logistic regression provides that
can be very helpful depending on the
problem that you're working on we'll
talk about sort of how to select from
the different algorithms that are at
your disposal at the end but in Python
the way you would do that this is going
to start to look very familiar the great
thing about scikit-learn is you just
pull in that model from a different part
of the package the it worked pretty much
exactly the same so that's pretty cool
ok support vector machines I like to
think of support vector machines like
advance to draw a line through it and
there's kind of two advancements that
are that are relevant here one of them
is that they have a better definition of
terrible than just the old school linear
discriminant stuff that they were
working on in the 50s and 60s and the
other problem with that you may be
thinking of is that toy problem I showed
earlier it was very easy to draw a line
and the data was shaped in such a way
that that line divided things right but
what if your data is not shaped in a way
that you can draw a line through it what
if you have like a cluster of spam
emails in the middle of
a scatterplot and everything around it
is not spam it's gonna be hard to draw a
line that's PMS can handle this through
transforming your data to a higher
dimensional space I'll show what that
means right now so here's an example of
data in one dimension right so we just
have numbers along a number line you can
think about and the way that this data
is oriented if we try to draw a line to
separate it we're gonna have a bad time
right we're gonna no matter which side
we call blue and which side would call
red we're gonna get three wrong here we
use scoot it over here we're still gonna
get three wrong there's no way to divide
this with a line it's just not going to
work but without gathering any
additional data per se we can do a
little bit of sort of a math trick on
this in order to in order to actually be
able to divide this with a line and
within an SVM that's the kernel trick so
kernel basically means you're you're
transforming data from a lower dimension
to a higher dimension in this case all I
did to do this was pretend these are
numbers and we just take the square of
each number right just take the square
of each number and assign that as a new
feature so now we're in a higher
dimensional space we transform that data
we didn't actually really add like any
information per se we just took the
information we already had and augmented
it and now we can draw a line through it
so it's like magic this is this was what
people were really excited about this
when they came up with this now you can
get much more advanced than this when
you're talking about kernels there's
lots of really clever ways of of getting
outside of or being able to handle
things that aren't shaped like lions so
here's some plots I stole from the
scikit-learn documentation you can see
some examples here in the middle this is
a linear SVM meaning there's no kernel
really being applied it's just dividing
it with a line and you can see it's
really struggling with some of these
shapes and on the right here is what's
called an RBF SVM or a radial basis
function that's probably one of the more
popular kernels to use with
with a support vector machine and you
can see that it's creating these really
complex shapes because of how it does
the transformation rbf's are really cool
I'd love to talk more about them today
but don't have time but look into it or
maybe keep your eyes peeled for a future
talk the other thing I mentioned that
SVM's do differently is a better
definition of terrible and so if you
remember that first problem I was
showing you you can draw a line through
it like this and we separate we only get
one wrong this is a good line right we
could have also drawn the line like this
or like this and and all of these would
have had the same sort of terribleness
rating right and so how do we decide
between we have all this empty space and
as you increase the dimensions of your
data there's going to be more and more
empty space where you could potentially
draw that line how do you decide where
in that empty space that you put the
dividing line because you could just you
could put it right here and this is
right up against those blue data points
it seems like maybe that's not the best
choice so other idea that SVM's
introduced is this idea of a margin the
margin is the distance between the
decision boundary and the closest point
so in this case you can see the the
margin in yellow here and if we move
that line down towards the blue points
the margin is going to shrink now it's
really skinny and if we scoot that line
up towards the top the margin is going
to grow so in addition to having this
ability to plug in kernels SVM's also
try to maximize the margin which
essentially means you know in the
absence of data since we don't have any
points in this in this sort of liminal
space I guess try and put that dividing
plane right in the middle just because
we don't have any you know if we update
it later we have more data points than
we can handle then we might move that
that boundary but if we don't know just
stick it right in the middle that's
gonna do better on higher dimensional
stuff and instances where you have less
data than a traditional linear
discriminant okay so doing this in
Python again pretty straightforward
entry
for the first time here you'll see that
when you create the model this is when
you can kind of put in some of the the
parameters the things that you can tune
about any of these models the ones I've
showed so far didn't show those yet but
in this case this is a setting the
kernel to be polynomial and the degree
to be two that's exactly what I showed
you earlier with squaring the thing
right so that's something you could do
the most popular kernel probably for for
using an SVM is the RBF one because you
can read more about it but it can it can
handle all kinds of sort of wavy shapes
and it actually uses the data itself as
the new space that you transform it into
it's kind of mind breaking but but
anyway you can you can set that to
whatever you like in there and all that
stuff's in the documentation okay so
let's get away from lines there are
other methods that you could come up
with to sort things into categories
right k nearest neighbors is one of
these I think of K nearest neighbors is
kind of like the you know on Amazon when
you see like customers who bought X also
bought Y K nearest neighbors is kind of
that approach to classification what do
what is a similar case look like and
using that to infer like what you might
call this an email so we have a new
email up here and we're just gonna say
what's the nearest neighbor the one near
well it's the one nearest neighbor which
meaning what's the most similar email is
it spam so the most similar email to
this email is spam so we'll call this
email spam the K is referring to the
fact that you could change that number
right increased beta to we're gonna look
at the two most similar emails and take
the average of those they're both spam
so this one's spam one thing to be aware
of with this is it turn tweaking that K
really changes the properties in the
boundary that come out of using a
classifier like this so if you have a
really low K like K equals 1 this point
down here it's kind of unclear whether
this this spam email is an outlier or
whether that's part of a broader pattern
we maybe don't have enough data to know
but the email that's right next to it is
gonna latch on to that and call it spam
because it doesn't know any better as
you increase K k equals 2
now you have one spam and one not spam
different KNN implementations deal with
this in different ways sometimes you
just say well whichever one is more
common we'll take that one sometimes you
say well whichever one is more close
we'll take that one but as you increase
K it becomes kind of less sensitive to
those nuances and the data and I have a
figure in a second that will kind of
demonstrate that another piece from this
I can't learn documentation and you
really can't see it on this screen when
you look at my slides later there are
figure attributions here
I didn't whip all of these up myself but
they're really instructive to look at so
you can see K nearest neighbors in the
middle here this these are decision
boundaries for K and n classifiers and
you can tell these are definitely not
lions right it's handling very sort of
complex shapes and the data and it looks
kind of a jagged e and funky compared to
the linear SVM on the right which can
only draw a line through things and then
this is an example of this is from a
blog post from Burton to wild a really
great blog post on on KNN if you want to
learn more about it but you can see on
the left here is K equals 1 and then K
equals 5 and then K equals 25 for the
same classification problem and if you
look at that border it's kind of there's
a smoothing effect as you increase the K
so you give up catching sort of like
nuance in the data but you're also less
likely to focus in on something in your
training set that was just kind of weird
it kind of goes from this weird sort of
like island looking coastline to
something that's more smooth as you
increase K okay so doing this in psyche
at larren it's gonna look a lot like the
things that I've already showed you set
the number of neighbors as one of those
knobs that you can tweak on the model
fit predict etc all right decision tree
learners so this is another approach and
this is kind of like if we were to look
at this these emails and let's say we
were going to make a flowchart for a
human to look at this chart and be able
to decide whether this email is spam or
not right
so the first thing we might do in making
that flowchart we want to sort of
eliminate as many of those dots from the
running as possible with one slice along
one of the along one of the features so
in this case we might say if X is
greater than there is less than three I
think I flipped my labels on there but
if X is less than three
oh no that's right if X is less than
three we know it's not spam whatever X
is right this is some feature of the
data that we came up with and this is
artificial your stuffs usually not gonna
look this clean if it does you're
probably gonna kick asset at classifying
it but but so that's our first cut right
everything left of this line we don't
have to think about anymore our next one
will be right here because we could say
okay everything above this line if Y is
greater than four then it's not spam
here if X is less than five then it's
spam right and now we've sort of covered
the entire space and this is what our
decision boundary looks like so it's not
a line it's actually a like a block
right and the more freedom you give to a
decision tree it can make all kinds of
little intricate chains of blocks and
cuts and things like that if you don't
give it very much freedom or very much
depth to the tree then it's gonna be
sort of more macro shapes like this keep
in mind again this is a 2d and once you
start to get into higher dimensional
space these are going to capture a lot
more nuance than than like a square but
squares in seven dimensions look friggin
crazy you can't even imagine what they
look like really at least I can't there
maybe there's some mathematicians here
but okay so right so doing this in
scikit-learn again pull in the model it
predict another kind of cool thing
that's unique about the decision tree
and particularly with scikit-learn if
you install pi dot which is another
another library that allows you to draw
these graphviz
visualizations it'll actually spit out
the literal flowchart that is what you
trained on this model which if you're
using this to come up with something
that's like more like a
algorithm that's going to be executed by
people like more like a heuristic then
this is actually really cool right and
then I mentioned that if you give a
decision tree a lot of freedom it can
really cut a bunch of different shapes
and get very intricate that's a blessing
and a curse it means that they're very
prone to overfit on little nuances in
your training data if you give them a
lot of freedom so in this case you know
up in that top left corner you might not
want to assume that every data point
that you see up there is spam in the
future I didn't come up with the most
like egregious overfitting example here
but it's something to be aware of with
those I'll talk more about it at the end
as well okay one way you might
compensate for that is with an ensemble
model and these are growing popular
these days and ensemble models there's a
bunch of different methods for doing
this but it really means making a bunch
of models and combining them in some way
so the first one I'm going to talk about
is bagging and bagging basically means
you're gonna split your training set by
randomly sampling it into smaller sets
you're gonna train a model on each of
those smaller sets so in this case let's
train some decision trees we end up with
decision boundaries that look like this
so now we have three models we have a
new data point we have a new email
coming in we want to say is this spam or
not so we give that data point to every
model and each model says that's not
spam or that spam that's not spam and
then we take a majority vote right so if
you look at this decision boundary in
the middle this is an example of a
decision tree maybe overfitting on the
training data that you gave it right
it's calling this little region in the
bottom left spam but the other two don't
because they didn't have that point in
their set because they all have sub
samples of your full data so they're
actually going to out vote that over fit
problem in the middle in the middle
model usually you're gonna train a lot
more than just three when you do an
ensemble that kind of depends on what
what method you're using but our final
answer here would be not spam another
way to think of this is the decision
boundary for for a bagged classifier is
really like
the some the decision boundaries of its
components so if you lay them on top of
each other you end up with a shape
that's much more nuanced and smoother
than you would get if you just trained a
decision tree on this overall but
there's a lots of ways to do ensembles
random forest is one that you've maybe
heard of because a it's kind of a fun
name I think somebody should named their
band random forest if they haven't
already but but it's also a group
popular I don't know probably in the
last decade I would say but it's kind of
like bagging but at each time that you
are making those splits in your decision
tree you also constrain randomly the
features you're allowed to make a split
along so this is sort of adding more
randomness to the to the to the process
in order to avoid making those overfits
on these really sort of like corner
cases in the training data because you
might not
you're only allowing the tree to like
pay attention to certain parts of the
email so it doesn't zero and on this one
really weird email you got from your
uncle or whatever extra trees stands for
extremely randomized trees and this is
adding even more randomness where not
only are you splitting your training set
and can and constraining the features
but you're also not even making the
optimal split every time that you every
time that you make a split for the
decision tree it's crazy to me that this
works and you need to do some more
reading to understand why but you
compensate by training it with a ton of
trees right so when you do extra trees
you have a super huge ensemble and can
despite the fact that you're not making
optimal choices on each individual one
the aggregate of them are supposed to
sort of catch some of the broader
patterns in your data set so these two
depending on what your what your data
looks like this is really true of
everything I'm talking about today will
have different performance
characteristics sometimes one is better
than the other
sometimes one will be sort of more
prone to focusing on an outlier so it
might do better at first and then you
put it into production you realize oh I
didn't you know properly test this and
it's it's overfitting some other some
other ensembles methods voting so
bagging kind of has a voting component
right but you could imagine rather than
splitting your training set and training
the same kind of model on all the
subsets what if you took your entire
training set and just trained a bunch of
different types of models so you train a
cannon classifier you train an SVM you
train a decision tree and then you have
all of those different methods vote you
see this a lot in people who are trying
to squeeze like the last few decimal
places out of something I think the
winner the Netflix prize voted like a
bunch of models together and I have a
visual that will kind of show you what
effect that has it's kind of cool can
help compensate for some of the
weaknesses in each of the individual
methods boosting is I guess it's sort of
an augmentation of an ensemble method
and boosting is really popular right now
because it's can produce really good
results in boosting when you're you're
still training a set of models and
hatton taking the consensus of them but
so let's say we're boosting with
decision trees you train the first tree
and because this is supervised learning
we know the correct answers so we can
look at the ones that we the first tree
got wrong when you train the second tree
you overemphasize focusing on the ones
that the first tree got wrong when you
train the third tree you overemphasize
the ones that the first tube got wrong
so it's kind of cool because you're
almost building a team of classifiers to
work together and complement each
other's like strengths and we are really
each other's weaknesses
and so that can you can imagine how that
might result in sort of an ensemble that
can perform better than just creating
those things randomly okay so this is a
another cool figure from the secular
documentation showing the example of
that voting classifier
at the top you have a decision tree and
a KN and then a kernel SVM this looks
like probably a polynomial one but I'm
not sure and you can see these have
their quirks right so the kernel SVM
because of the transformation there's
this kind of artifact in the bottom
right where in this area where we
haven't seen any data for some reason it
thinks it should be red and the other
classifiers don't see that way because
that doesn't really I don't know makes
sense and let's see yeah and then also
on this sort of like middle left part
you can see the kernel SVM and the
decision tree think that that area
should be red where the where the KNN
kind of like starts to recede for some
reason so these are kind of quirks of
these different models but then in the
bottom right here is a voting classifier
of all three of them and you can see
that those the because you're sort of
using these different approaches they
are cancelling out each other's each
other's sort of quirks or short
shortcomings I mean without having data
in those areas we actually don't know if
they're shortcomings maybe maybe that is
maybe the SVM is getting it correctly
but but that's kind of an example of
what what voting can do for teaming up
classifiers together of course then you
know that's more computation because you
know you've got to train all these
different models and every time you do a
classification you have to call all of
them so that's one of the downsides I
guess all of this stuff is inside cute
learn I'm not going to get into the
details but rest assured the ensemble
module has all of this stuff in it so
usually at this point the question that
I get is okay cool so you just taught me
about all of these things which one of
these what do I use which one of these
do I pick and the answer is that they'll
perform differently on different data
that has different characteristics and
so really the safest method would be to
test as many of them as you can try out
different parameters and this is kind of
the science part of data science in some
ways it's how do I experimentally verify
that using this method over that method
or statistically verify I guess this
method over
method is going to produce better
results that said these classifiers have
some different characteristics that
might help you sort of point in the
right direction when you're getting
started so a few of those we talked
about being able to draw boundaries that
aren't lines providing probability
estimates is another thing depending on
you could imagine if you are building an
email application you might want your
spam filter to treat an email that
you're 95% sure is spam different from
one that you're like 51% sure is spam
and some of these models can also tell
you how important the features that you
fed into them are to the final result
which can be really nice when you're
developing these models because you
could throw out the ones that aren't any
use it might give you some intuition
towards what what features you know
we're really contributing or that kind
of thing so I'm going to kind of fly
through these tables
I'll put these slides up so that you can
look at them later but logistic
regression you're stuck with a linear
boundary but they can provide
probability estimates and if you scale
your data such that the features are on
the same sort of magnitude so you don't
have like a percentage in one column and
like millions of dollars in the other
then those coefficients of the line can
actually give you a clue towards which
of those features are most important
right SVM's
they can do nonlinear as we saw that
they can't really provide probability
estimates you can kind of fake it but
it's very computationally intensive and
they can't really give you any feature
importances kns absolutely nonlinear you
can kind of get probability you're
really getting more like shades of gray
but if you think about a K equals 5
classifier it could tell you well four
out of the five were mm or three out of
the five neighbors where spam that's
precisely a probability but it does give
you some more nuance than just yes or no
don't really give you feature
importances naive Bayes I didn't cover
in this talk it's a probability based
way of building a classifier and it's a
little harder to visualize and fit into
45 minutes but just for your reference
on these tables yes they can do
nonlinear they're built on probabilities
so they're great at providing
probabilities and no they can't really
tell you how important a feature is to
the model decision trees yes nonlinear
not no probabilities they can kind of
give you importance based on how many
times you made a slice in the in the
flow chart along one feature or another
right so in our example we did it twice
along the x-axis and only once along the
y-axis so that might tell you that if
you had to throw one of those out
there's more information contained in
the x-axis than the Y it's not perfect
but might give you some intuition
ensemble models can do nonlinear can
kind of provide probability by knowing
how many of the classifiers voted for
the the out sort of resulting answer and
depending on their component parts they
can give you those importances if you
use things that can give you importances
that can give you importances boosted
models exactly the same a couple other
things when you're putting these into
production that you might care about can
you update them with new data without
having to retrain from scratch and are
they easy to do in parallel on something
like spark or even just if you have like
a quad-core computer or something you
want to use all of those logistic
regression the answer to both of these
is kind of people have come up with
methods for refitting an existing
logistic regression model and for
training them in parallel they won't
perform identically to if you just
retrain from scratch or if you read if
you train one on on a machine on a
single machine rather than in parallel
but but it'll kind of work if you need
it to SVM's depends on your kernel an
RBF is is a tricky thing to update with
new data because the space that you
transform your data up into depends on
the data itself so when you get new data
that's base changes you can't really
just kind of like barely move that line
a little bit you kind of have to restart
from scratch but if you're just doing
something like Paul
like I was showing with squaring things
or even just a linear one like you just
want it to be a really good straight
line those you can refit parallelizing
again the RBF is kind of difficult to do
across many machines or take example to
take advantage of that but other kernels
that's not as hard k it ends are great
for both of these you can imagine
parallelizing you just split your data
set across a bunch of computers and they
all return the sort of closest neighbors
and then you can figure it out from
there and they're very easy to update
with new data because you're just that
the model is essentially the points and
the distance between them naive Bayes
also great for both of these their
probability based so they're really just
counts and and and they're easy to
update using Bayes rule decision trees
not very good for both of these things
they're hard to update because as soon
as you have new data that split that you
made originally might not be the optimal
one anymore and they're kind of hard to
parallel wise but they're really fast to
train so that kind of makes up for it in
practice because you can just train a
bunch of them at an ensemble or just one
if that's what you're doing ensemble
models you can kind of update them with
new data because if you have you know a
hundred decision trees that you're
calling on to make the decision for you
if you have new data the old trees might
not necessarily take advantage of the
newly they don't take advantage of the
new labeled data but you could train
some new trees that do and add them to
the ensemble it's kind of an art
figuring out how you might adapt that
over time do you throw out the old ones
do you just end up with thousands of
decision trees but it's in theory kind
of possible if you if you really need to
do that and they're easy to parallel
wise right because you're doing exactly
the same thing on small subsets of the
data very easy to farm out on a cluster
or just across the course of your
computer boosted models same story with
updating them but they're harder to
parallel eyes because if you remember
you have to do things in order with a
boosted model you have to know how well
the first one did and
to train the second one then you have to
know how well the second one and the
first one did to train the third one so
harder to do now in inspark there are
methods to do pretty much all of this
stuff on like a spark cluster but
they're not all necessarily going to
take advantage of the fact that you're
doing it across many machines or many
processors okay so I got a wrap-up but
some other quirks keep in mind with an
SVM picking a different kernel have a
lot of impact on how your classifier
performs in KNN you have to define what
similarity is that's something that I
glossed over but it makes a big
difference depending on the type of data
that you have the other thing about KN
ends is that they're what are called
lazy learners they're very fast to train
and they're very well comparatively slow
they're still computers right
comparatively slow to classify compared
to other methods can be good can be bad
depending on your application naivebayes
you have to choose a distribution
another cool thing about naivebayes is
that they can deal with like nulls
basically when you're missing a feature
for a data point decision trees we
mentioned both of these things already
right you can get literal flow charts
out of them and they're very sensitive
to outliers ensemble models they're less
prone to overfitting than their
component parts which is pretty cool
kind of allows you to make use of
decision trees where you have to be
really careful if you're just training
one if you make a hundred or 200 of them
that they can kind of compensate for
each other
boosted models they have more parameters
to tweet than an ensemble right and
they're also slightly more prone to
overfitting an ensemble but if you tune
those things correctly they can perform
better than an ensemble so this is why
when you see sort of the most popular
Kaggle winners who are squeezing out the
last few decimal points of an analysis a
lot of times they're using some crazy
boosted model or some voting algorithm
of many boosted models or things like
that so in practice I my personal
opinion is that's not always necessarily
what you care about there are lots of
these other properties such as being
able to paralyze something being able to
explain it to your boss that might
matter
more than squeezing out the last decimal
point but it's just something to be
aware of if accuracy is like of the
utmost importance okay so I didn't leave
a lot of time for questions but but it's
lunchtime now so I'll stick around I'm
happy to talk about this stuff it's
really fun thanks for listening to my
talk